Okay, we are back
live.
Hi. Today we are going to do more
simulation side work. Still have some
experiments going in the background.
We'll be checking on them uh
periodically. But uh yeah, generally I
think we're going to be doing
more on the simulation side, which will
be fun. Kind of just starting the work
that we are going to plan on doing a lot
more of after 3. Starting it a little
early since we have to wait for
experiments and stuff
anyways. Switch the view
over. Get rid of all this. Need any of
this.
Leave these in the
background and right
here.
Okay. So, first thing we're going to do
here, we're going to try to adjust
the environment to have a
um more reasonable set of observation.
Believe we got a score of 21 or so
before.
Check
have to restart the
container. Hi, captain. Pretty much have
Impulse Wars done. Need to finish
debugging my new binding. Changes my end
memory in a weird
way. Bindings change my M's memory in a
weird way. How recently did you pull? I
fixed the
uh I fixed a weird
memory thing
bug. Yeah, I fixed a major freaking
crazy memory layout bug.
Um,
yesterday got a bad I PR a bad uh deck
ref. I didn't catch it. I was reviewing
be a bad idea to run. That would not
have caught
it. I had to give you an
idea. Um, let me think. How long did I
have to run it for?
It was like in the hundreds of millions
of steps initially until I and then I
had to find a lucky seed to repro it
faster. It was a whole ordeal. It took
me six hours
yesterday. It was like a very rare bug.
Like basically Python's garbage
collection had to
trigger at like a really wonky time as
well. Well, what's your
issue? I can take a look at your M and
see if there's anything obvious.
weird. Is this consistent? If it's if
you have something consistent and like
it still happens with um you know a
debugger and everything, then I can look
into what the heck is going
on. It's a heck of a lot easier to fix
something like that than it is to fix
the crazy curse thing uh from
consistent. All right. Yeah, we can
definitely look at that. That's
not. You want me to look at that with
you
now? I wouldn't mind doing
that. Yep. No worries. Whenever you're
good. I think I got to go flip a tire
outside in a sec, but other than that,
I'm good for uh I'm good to work on Sim
stuff today.
going to keep working on the
terraforming sim then in the meantime.
Let's see if this observation produces
roughly the same result or
not. I should start being having all
these on Neptune as well.
This is probably very poorly normalized,
right?
Okay. So, we do want this divide
now to do very nicely for
us. That should produce a pretty big
jump in per Actually, we're going to put
this on
Neptune and we're going to
do Neptune
Make the terrain gen
faster. It's be annoying the way it
was just a basic comb architecture,
right? Yeah, this is just a basic
is. And this will be our first
baseline on terraform.
bad. Definitely have to optimize some
stuff.
Well, they're cutting out like this
massive swath right now, right?
Okay. Okay. So, next thing we're going
to want to do is
uh make it so that they don't chunk all
the dirt at the same time, All right.
Yeah. So, we have like these massive
pillars right now.
These piles of dirt are like ridiculous,
right?
um globe time
scale? Wait.
32. But then this was not what I was
seeing, right?
Okay. So somehow this has
254 as the max
Perfect. So we not only did we uh we
fix memory bug
Hi, we spoke recently about my ant
calling product. Awesome. Welcome. Would
you be available to discuss it from 4 to
5 EST today? Of
course. Let's see.
add
myself
alarm. Yeah, I can do that call
privately or here on stream. Either
way, if you haven't dropped by before,
welcome. I kind of just do reinforcement
learning all day and stream stuff.
Currently working on a terraforming sim.
this. They're not quite ants. They're
little robots that run around and like
eat up
dirt. Very early project.
the All right, that's nothing I need to
deal
with. Got a semi delivering or a flatbed
delivering a I don't even know what
equipment that
So, I kind of have to decide on the
units here,
chunks. Yeah, this is actually a fine
height then, right?
32 32 and 16. That's 16 ft high tops.
That's about
right. 16 foot high pile of dirt.
be
times 0 divide by max dirt
have to do some optimization on the
startup time of this. I don't like
having this end taking so long. I think
we even should do that next before we do
anything
255. We get our baseline and then we
have to start looking for uh ways to
make this thing
[Music]
faster. Okay. Okay. So, dozer max
velocity
five, which is 2 and 1/2
ft in a tick.
might be one of those M's where it
actually makes sense to animation with
it as
well. Well, this would just run it
really fast at the
moment. Kind of fine.
Okay. Yeah, we're getting immediately
better training performance
though,
right? Are we working off dev or 3? 3.
Rio is just dev as of uh like two days
ago. It's the Well, where were adding
all the new
stuff? Yeah, that's
breakout. Yeah. So, this is way better.
So, with the bug
fixed, this thing actually trains in a
reasonable fashion.
Yeah, this is way better than we've ever
seen.
decent
enough. Let's eval this real quick.
bots. Oh, they do
stuff. Yeah, they try to
like I mean they're like cutting
directly through the terrain,
right? Trying
to cool. They definitely have more
coherent
movement. Okay, so now what we do, I
need to get this thing to at least
initialize a little bit faster.
to what do we
think? I've got vecum m=
now. So I can divide this by
eight. Four ms. Let's see how fast this
right? That's way better.
Okay, so we can punt then on speed for
now because we can just use more cores
and we're
happy. Let me see if I can get half
cheated to run real quick as well
because there's a guy asking about it in
the
Discord. Get this out for him real
quick.
network. Yeah, that's a little awkward,
isn't it?
And then this is just default major like
this is our default basically.
I thought a little about bit about what
you said last stream about training a
policy using the puffer
stack and making it deterministic by
taking
max.
remember to be fair. Our stack is not
much of a stack. It's pretty simple.
It's pretty short and simple
code. Like if you're trying to mess
around in SP3 or or like any basically
if you're using anything other than
clean RL, Puffer is going to be simpler.
The only thing simpler than Puffer is
clean RL and
like like Puffer is just built like
trying to be clean RL but really really
fast with like a few extras. But trying
to not make a total mess of everything.
No problem.
state and the policy has learned that
it's
like okay
Yeah. What's the problem with that? Like
a max function is allowed to break ties.
It's just going to take the first one.
And also that's never going to happen
because like you'd have to have the
exact same float.
I don't understand. Like you're asking
for a deterministic algorithm, but you
don't want it to be deterministic on
even
splits. It's going to be stochastic at
training time and deterministic at eval
time. If you want it to be deterministic
at eval time, you can trivially also
make it stochastic at eval time if you
want. It's like a oneline change.
learning. It's learning.
You like 10
Oh, you ran 50 million,
dummy. Wanted 5 mil, not 50 mil.
This type of stuff is great when people
ask me for little things like this cuz
it doesn't take very long and I get to
fix bugs here and
Yes. Yeah. So, this has a this is a
weird freaking network.
box is continuous is
true. So this should
have decoder mean
Decoder log standard deviation, right?
doesn't have decoder log standard
deviation for some
reason. I see decoder mean
All
right. Had to help flip a tire.
Whoa. So I This thing doesn't freaking
render.
Okay, we can get rid of
the wait missing one
required
this. We'll get this guy as Majoko
thing.
Remove that Twitch
bot.
Cool. We just fixed this thing for this
guy.
We'll see how that is. I'm going to go
use the restroom real quick and uh I
know maybe start on some
lips. Then we will uh go on Terraform,
get some coffee and all
that. Sure.
Oh, my watch was totally on the wrong
date. Knop in Discord and five.
Actually, perfect timing.
Captain, there's a restroom and I will
be right ready to uh jump on over.
Okay. So, it's the same. It's just
unstable.
It resets every 51 12 ticks
unstable. It resets every 51 12 ticks though.
else? I mean the next step would be to
do the uh the dirt capacity stuff,
right?
Yeah, I think that's the next
step. Bit weird that it's
um unstable like that
though. It's a bit disconcerting.
steps? Few
minutes probably
fine. Just hypers
maybe. Not like an obvious reason this
would be unstable to me.
Hey, man.
Hey, can you hear me? Yeah. How's it
going? Good. How you doing?
Too much release work, but I'm all
right.
Um, yeah. Um, I've I saw in Discord
you're pretty much done though, right?
We're getting pretty close. And then
Yes. Nice.
fork. All right, so I'm going to post
this in the
uh I'm going to post this in the general
voice chat like the link to this.
Well, first actually I guess let me
share my screen and then I'll just kind
of show you what's going on and then
I'll have you
reproduce have Loi. It's built directly
into Discord.
I see that. That's funny.
All right. So, we
got got some codes.
Yeah. So, um I've been running it with
the address sanitizer, but the address
sanitizer doesn't really find anything.
Um won't hurt though. Uhhuh. Uh I
modified it to run 1M just to make it as
fast as possible on the CPU. So, I'll
run it and I added some debug prints to
my code.
Um so yeah basically what's happening
here there's a lot um I'm getting this
error in box 2D basically
um instead of pointers to things it uses
like just uh like index or just like ID
strrus and the ID should never be zero
and it should never be above the max
worlds. The max world's basically just
you 16 so it's super high. Um, and you
can see basically I print at the
beginning stepm is just my cstep
function. I print out what the world
index is and it never really changes
because in this case I have one m
running. Um, but you can see it ends at
two here and then when I start stepm but
ends at zero and I print um, and I
actually I can do that just to show you.
So basically this is between this
None of my none of my code is called,
but this changes somehow. The address
sanitizer isn't uh triggered. Okay. And
this is it seems and this has been
happening as of new binding port. Yes.
And have you gotten the latest 30? Yeah,
this is rebase with 30.
Okay. So,
so I'll show you um this is
one of those rare times that you would
want
to I haven't even done that. It's
when you want what?
Okay.
So, what's that variable called?
So, it's just
uh uh e world ID like my M. It's in my
M. It's just like the world ID. Um, and
what's annoying about the new bindings,
for whatever reason with the Sython
stuff, I was able to get a full stack
trace when I was debugging, but when I
debug with GDB with the new bindings, it
only ever gives me like the current
function. If I do that, you can get a
full stack trace. What you have to do
though is you have to you have to
compile it with debug equals 1. And then
there's an LD preload. Debug equals
zero.
Oh, I mixed it up. Well, debug equals Z
is disable debug. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So,
um I tried that. Um I was also building
with CMake with debug. So, that should
do the same thing. You don't need CMake.
I just was found. We use the we use the
debug equals we use debug equals 1 in
our setup. Yeah, it it still wasn't
working with me for that for whatever
reason. But um well then you also need
there's an LD preload you need.
Yeah I have that. See okay and you are
not
getting you don't get traces from this.
No if you don't get traces from this
then I would expect that this is some
shenanigans with your CMake setup.
Well, so I did get a full I did get a
full stack trace with the address
sanitizer, which it when it I did find a
bug on my own code, but it was only when
I'm basically it was a bug in debug
logging, so it like wasn't a big deal,
but I fixed it. So I I was able to get
full stack traces, but when I GDB for
whatever reason, it seems like when the
Python code calls my C code, it just
doesn't give me a good stack trace,
which is very strange. You get like the
full frame or do you only get one
function?
I I get one function. So I have like
debug symbols are there because I'm able
to see what the functions called. I'm
able to list all the like arcs and
locals and everything, but I can't it
basically just says yeah like this box
function it was just called and nothing
else before it which is definitely not
true which is but if you had like typed
like back trace there's nothing there.
Yeah, that's very weird.
Yeah.
There should be a no omit stack like no
omit frame pointer or something, right?
Isn't that it?
Yeah. Hold on. I got to compile this
without you got
that sanitizer. Well, I guess I could
still LD preload, but it'll just take
longer.
Yeah. What was the LD preload? It just
straight up won't run without the LD
preload for me.
Yeah.
What I was going to suggest is if we
can, and I almost never have to do this.
You set a watch point on that variable.
Yeah, I tried that and that wasn't
working either for whatever reason. So,
yeah, if I just do
frame or back
trace. Oh, okay. Weird. Frame usually
shows. Maybe it was going to run one.
The back trace gives you the full trace.
Yeah, my bad. Yeah, I knew this already
though because I kind of figured it out.
Um I can set a watch on it. Um let me
see if it gives you I don't know if
watch points I don't know technically if
it watch I don't know how they work if
they um if whenever the memory changes
for any reason including like some
random address rewrite it'll do it.
But the thing is like once this is set,
it should never change.
Well, but it is changing. I know. So if
it changes at all. Okay. So if we can
watch that variable
What is it? I I forgot how to list break
points
now. Red one here. Breakpoint one.
Uh it's clear one.
Disable. Just disable it. It's fine.
Okay.
Oh, it it tells me when it's being
read, not just uh there's a way to set
it so you can only ch like do it on
change.
I'm not sure how to do that cuz that's
weird. Yeah. Let me
look. Like I again I almost never have
to do this.
okay. Forget how do I list the break
points? I I I was just doing that on
Thursday, but I
Okay. So, I'm going to
restart
and it was just watch
if not equal whatever it was.
Okay, this doesn't make sense because if
that If this was actually zero, this
would have Fox CD would have freaked out
already. That doesn't make any sense.
So, what was it? Watch this if what
value? Well, I think you have to set the
old value, but it's two. So, you can
just
do the stupid thing. The problem is the
problem with using Grock is every time I
open the damn thing, I end up opening
Twitter at the same time.
I guess that's what they want. Can you
not go like
Brock? Okay, you can technically
grock.com. Okay. Okay. I think hopefully
I Yeah, this is croc.com. Okay, there.
Way better. Now I can't get
sidetracked. Uh, set conditional watch.
Well, didn't it remember it? Can't you
just pull up the past combo?
See, no, cuz it's the the web version
other Oh, weird.
Watch variable if condition.
to watch if not equal
to let's
Ah, wait. Watch five is deleted because
the program has left the block in which
questions valid. Yeah, that's
Wait is left the block in which
expression is valid.
I
mean it
I guess I can try to get the memory
address. I think it's probably cuz
you're getting outside the spot where E
is valid, right? Cuz like E is
Well, E is my M and my M like it it the
memory of the M should be the same until
we stop training. Yeah, but I think it's
the it's not the address. It's like the
reference to E or whatever. Maybe I
think it's like the scope of the
function.
I wonder if I can watch like a specific
like if memory will do
better like watch this memory address
basically. You probably can. Is this
running through Python or just a C? This
is running through Python.
Slightly more complicated. I can't repro
this with my C. This is like only in
Yeah. So it's
something writing over most likely. Mhm.
So, I I remember uh we talked before and
you said that the address sanitizer
sometimes won't catch Well, it depends.
If you ever overrun memory, it'll catch
it. But, um in this case, it was
specifically the bug it wouldn't catch
was the deck ref because that all that
does is tells Python's garbage collector
to free it later at some point. Yeah,
but that's not what's happening here,
I'm pretty sure. Well, you have
recompiled since I pushed that fix.
Yeah.
Yep. Then it should be fine.
Yeah. I don't think it's that bug. That
was a bad bug to debug. Yeah, sounds
like it. Not fun. So, I mean, you have
Oh, man. It's when you call step the
first time or what is it? It's after you
call step like I don't know a certain
number of times. Um,
well, you can just put a step 192. For
some reason, it
succeeds. And then, oh, I don't log what
step we're at, but I bet you it's like
the same step every time. I'm just going
to quit out of this. Let me think.
trying to think how we can.
Okay, so idea.
Um, can we get a break point once the
thing has screwed up? I want to see the
rest of this truck. I want to see if
like surrounding memory
screwy. One
sec. I'm just going to if it's
consistently the same step, that would
be really weird.
I did get it to be the same step when I
was doing my deck ref stuff with like
the same seed and everything the other
day. Yeah, this isn't even the same
seed, but I think it's the
same. How do I reset this? There is a
default
seed unless you use time.
now if I just run
it like say twice and see what we're
at. Yeah.
192. So, interestingly enough, I only
Oh, wait. No, I don't. Um
Where' the other steps go? It's skipping
some.
Uh, yeah. 23. That is weird.
Is this async with multiple workers or
some Doesn't look like it. No.
So, so basically what's happening is
um the frame skip is making it like
update episode length because it's
basically like we're doing one m step
but multiple kind of like internal
steps. So, okay. So, I mean we can then
we can go to
like what
189 and like check it and then see if it
gets screwed up in your C or if it gets
screwed up by the external. All right.
One sec. I'm going to make sure we're
actually getting a different seed every
time
cuz
what different seed? Yeah.
But like I I would just go to like 189,
like put a break point when you hit 189
and then like step through and because
basically like I want to see if the if
it gets screwed up in your C like while
you're still in your C or if it gets
screwed up when it returns to the Python
and then that that something like screws
up the memores somehow. Yeah. Yeah, I'll
do that a sec. I just want to make sure.
Okay. Yeah. C to zero. Well, that's
weird.
So, why isn't I mean this is another
thing, but why isn't your why aren't
your bindings actually setting the seed
to be random?
Well, it's not by default. Well, first
of all, you actually have to use the
seed parameter. Um, if you have one, you
don't just you don't def you don't so
seed parameter when I'm calling like
puffer train or what?
Uh I I honestly don't even remember.
Like I haven't I basically just haven't
done with the C params. So okay, I
think that there is a
way. Like it honestly doesn't even
matter that much like most of the time
because the thing is you're making your
M's in a loop anyways in the C process.
So like let's say it's the same seed. Um
you're still going to get like different
maps and stuff because the RNG will
advance because you're on the same C
process.
Yeah, but I'm saying it's just helpful
for different training runs just to get
I don't know. You're not going to get
reproducible anyways unless you set
a whole bunch of other stuff in torch.
And what what I'm talking about is the
opposite. I'm saying if you're doing
different training runs and starting
with different starting seeds, you're
going to get you can you're more uh you
can do experiments and see, okay, yeah,
like these are more different. You're
still going to get that because of the
action the action variant still does
that. I know, but it's just like another
way. Anyway, yeah, let's go do that.
Like the randomness from the actions is
way more because you're running like a
thousand M.
I
hate how it doesn't save stuff between
sessions. That's annoying. I'm sure you
can do that. There is a way to do that.
Yeah.
actually yeah, I'm just going to bring
it to that
I think we're going to run into the same
issue though. Um like if I just do break
or hold
break where is that? Oh that one s that
one will survive um across bounds. Why
do you think? because I did the watch
before and nothing. I don't know why
watch point doesn't survive, but I do
know that this one will this one will
survive. Yeah, but you have to actually
like the thing is you'd have to put like
some conditional or whatever.
Yeah, that should do it, right?
I don't know. I don't usually set him
like that. Try
it. Nope.
Bro,
I think you have to break at a line
count. Yeah. Or function.
Function name or line count.
I typically just put I just put like a
dump conditional in my code and then I
break inside of it.
That makes sense. If probably something
like
that. Try that.
Okay. So, how do we go one frame skip
forward? Just one frame.
I think it's step.
No, that's one function. So, unless
you're in a loop.
I don't mean one stack frame. I mean
one like one end frame.
Oh, like go through the M once. Well,
here's the thing though. I can guarantee
that there should be command to step out
of this function because what what I
need I know when this function ends the
world ID is still fine because if I go
back up here
uh right here. So, we have end step m
cuz we're at start right now. Yeah. End
stepm 189. It's two. And then we start.
Isn't it just up?
Huh? I think it's just up to up a frame
and then you connect line or whatever.
Well, then you're going too far, aren't
you? Yeah, you went too far. I just want
to see what's above that.
Well, you can see with the back trace
this one of the few commands I actually
use.
Okay, we're at
step.
Keep doing what you're doing. Hope you
make it. Thanks.
[Music]
Um, I apologize if I butchered your
name. Step n argument n means step end
times or until program stops for another
reason. Step program. Oh, until it
reaches a different source line. So,
yeah, I think step is what we want.
But the thing is though, we can't print.
Can we print? That is just go to like
run the next line of code. Yeah.
Okay. So, now we're at the start of step
M 189. Where's the world ID thing? Right
here.
Okay. Like you can like start going here
like one line at a time.
Yeah.
Well, wait. Now I should be able
Yeah. Well, wait. Now I should be able to do watch because I know what happens
Okay. So, I guess it's the next call.
Yeah. And between calls, right?
Yeah. More likely it's between calls.
Yeah. What do we have? Let me go take a
quick look at Vex step for you. Well,
okay.
You're using Vex? Yeah.
Uh yeah,
I missed it. I mean, the thing is this
kind of just calls your this kind of
just a straight up loop over your your
M's, you know? Yeah, is all it is.
I know. I'm so confused this is
happening.
Whoa. What's that?
Uh, I'm stepping. So, I just stepped
[Music]
um I'm not sure I'm in There's a ref
count
of 142,000 references.
Yeah,
that seems weird.
Um, so I stepped out of vexep.
Um, and then it is just Python whatever.
Then I have no idea what just that's the
that's like you're in the Python
internals. Yeah, I'm going to break a
vex step. What was it? Is it just ve_ep?
Yes.
when my tiny box is
here. We're getting the servers
delivered today.
Nice. The uh our old servers are getting
here.
I didn't mean to continue to step
boxes? Tiny boxes. Uh 6x490s per box.
Oh, wow. Get two of them.
So, okay. Now, I'm going to enable a vex
step and I'm just going to continue
until we call vexep
again. Okay, so I want to go down
to 520.
the old one.
Hello, track me.
Welcome. My bad. I have the check.
Okay. Yeah. Somehow this got changed.
It got changed where? What? What?
between two things.
So in between the vexstep calls, it
seems to have gotten changed.
Okay, so that would make
sense. Um,
so like this seems like another weird
internal Python bug maybe, but a
different one. Yay.
Uh, okay. So,
can you try one thing for me real quick?
Yeah. Can you just go to the end of
binding
file
and binding.h.
Yeah.
Go where?
Oh, my bad. I didn't see the right side
of your screen. Um, so just like look
for deck
ref. It's got to be uh Yeah. Okay, good.
Just comment out every instance of deck
ref.
That all of them should be. Yeah. Did
you do a find replace? Yeah. Okay, good.
So, just try that. That'll cause it to
leak a tiny bit of memory, but then it
that should basically tell Python not to
free anything. And I'll just double
check this is working. ve in it.
That should basically tell it to just
not free or not to free any of the
things that we're doing.
I'm just going to make sure it's
actually like this is actually going to
compile because that
So, to be fair, this happens when I was
using your build, too. This isn't like a
weird CMake thing. Um, I'm just using
CMake because it's easier to switch
between debug and release because I have
to rebuild the Box 2D archive every time
otherwise like
manually. Why isn't it Am I using it
wrong? I'm binding. It shouldn't be.
It's weird. Yeah, at this point at this
point I don't like if you just want to
leave it on CMake like in like this
internal sub I don't care. It's f I just
like I want the M to work out of the box
with the rest of puffer lib um as first
priority. And I want to have you know
decent train models on the M and I want
it to not have memory bugs.
Yeah. Well, no. I can I can get it to
So, to get it to work, I think I'm going
to leave the CMake in, but it's going to
be totally optional. Like, you'll be
able to run it without CMake, but I'm
just going to keep using CMake because
that's fine. Make it. Yeah. But anyway,
um I'm not sure why it's building not
this my
includ. Yeah, I give it the M. I give it
that because if I remove this, it
shouldn't be able to find Mbinding.h.
finding? Oh, it just it just includes it
like this.
Okay, so that should still include it.
Fine. Guess I didn't need that.
Or if I just do something completely
bad, it should just fail the
build. Yeah.
Okay, that looks promising.
You're just trying to make sure it's
actually building. Yeah.
Is exit. Yeah, I guess that is a thing.
Yeah. Cool. Okay, it works. All right.
So, now
I have a raven or a crow or something.
Mess on the bird feeder.
Yeah. All right. Um, let's see then.
So, do you have any you do have
freeze where your code in general,
right? Freeze some stuff. Uh, yeah, but
only uh
um I I'm make sure
that like my M cleanup function isn't
called because I print and nowhere in
here is it called. But you free don't
you free stuff elsewhere? cuz I'm just
wondering like if there's a use after
free. Um yeah, the the dress sanitizer
would guess catch that though.
Well, but what
if Yeah, I guess it would, wouldn't it?
Mhm. I'm trying to think if there's
something where like you freeze some
stuff and then because you call it
through Python, which is allocating a
bunch of dynamically, that
overwrites your memory.
I'm gonna see if I can break on like the
ve
itself.
So if I Yeah, if I run this again, it
should load the new shared object,
right? I imagine. I actually don't know.
Well, it doesn't matter. We didn't
actually change anything. We changed
anything and then changed it back. So,
it should be the
same. Okay. So, I
break at Yeah. I stop only that and then
I stop at this. I'll just disable seven
because that's just every vex step. No,
actually I
won't. All right. What I'm going to do
is I'm going to start another watch
point on
um okay.
So
[Music]
Okay. I forget. Can you do conditional
watch? Watch watch that if
And I'll disable seven so we're not
stopping at every backst
step and
continue. Uh yeah, I thought that might
happen. Watch
eight boy.
Mhm. I can't actually watch it. It's so
annoying
because it doesn't survive the scope.
No, maybe can make it a global.
Okay. Yeah, it seems like if I watch the
memory address, it might work.
right, it's continuing. I think it's
just really slow because it's checking
this memory address probably like every
step, but it shouldn't take too long
because it just has to do Python stuff.
It doesn't have to step a million times.
But I don't know. Python stuff is
probably a lot going on.
Python
slow. Yeah.
This is a really
Oh, okay. It's doing something just
extremely
slowly. Okay, this is extremely slowly
actually. I broke right before printing
and then it took like 30 seconds to
actually do the print. This is going to
take like an
fast. This is just GDB. I mean, I guess
it's just it's always just check it
memory dressed after probably every
assembly instruction, which is
expensive, I guess. I don't know.
I don't know how often. That would be
crazy expensive.
Yeah. I don't know if it's after every
assembly instruction, but definitely
after every like source line or
something.
Oh, here's
FedEx. I got to go make sure uh this is
probably all our servers. I'll be right
back.
Hey,
captain. You there?
Yeah. I'm really still waiting for
something to happen. Uh, okay. Cool. I
will start unpacking some boxes in the
background. I will come check back here
and there, see uh if you need help.
Yeah, I'm probably just going to do
something else because this is honestly
might take like a half hour or something
to go through. Okay. Well, let me know.
Yeah, we'll do
though. Any progress?
Captain, you're muted.
Okay, we have uh deliveries
accepted. Bird feeders called
check myself for ticks and other and uh
servers also there potentially one of
them's plugged in. I got to check if it
works. Oh, nice. any freaking
ticks doing that?
You have like tall grass out there.
They're just their ticks freaking
everywhere. And the thing is I can't
even tell because I have so many just
random ass bug bites that like I can't
even feel like oh that itches or that
doesn't feel right cuz like my I just am
constantly itchy.
Yeah.
Like I have like I don't know like
probably 50 bites all over me right now.
Um well I found the cause of the error I
think. Okay.
Um so it turned out to be
uh this line right here. So basically
aggregating over logs.
Let me see your log struct. And yeah so
I'm not really sure why. Let me let me
see your log strct. Yeah this is my log
strct. Um, I have a bunch of arrays of
floats, but everything is a float. And
does that get counted correctly? So, I
did like a Yeah, I did a size of and I
manually counted up all the fields and
it seemed to line up. So, I'm really
confused what the issue is. It seems to
be an off by one, though. Wait, is that
your log? Where's N? N's right here.
Wait, drone
stats. stats.
Yeah. And drone stats just direct full
floats.
So when that's put in memory, that
doesn't get any header. That's just
Yeah, that just gets those floats in
memory. Yep.
It's an off by one.
Yeah. So if you see
um so basically um what I found
was so I guess your uh code is setting
all like zeroing out all the logs right
um but what's strange is or what I think
it makes it be off by one so everything
in here you can see in the M vlog is
zeroed out but then it goes and zeros
out the world ID as well for whatever
season. So,
um it seems like it's and I think
because
uh there's stats and then world ID is
right after it. I think world ID is
right after stats in memory. Yeah. So,
that was what caused that to happen. I'm
not sure why the size off by one. I
that's what I can't figure out because
it seems like num keys numbum keys is
299. Where is it? Yeah,
299, which seems to be correct. So, we
have one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14. I need
to double check
this. Plus,
um, one, two, three, four, five, six, 60
because num weapons is 10.
um times 4 cuz there's four max
drones plus one two three. Yeah.
299.
Yeah. So that should be correct. I don't
know why we're getting it off by one
here.
Well, can you print
the print the address out
of Let me think. You can get like logn,
right? Yeah, you can get the address of
log.n log n, right?
Yeah.
Um, it's just I think it's aggregate,
right? Um,
uh, yeah, aggra get.
Okay.
So, that was supposed to be zeroed
out, right?
That should be the aggregate. The
aggregate isn't. It should be the M
vlog.
Okay. Well, that's what I meant that it
get like Oh, okay.
I should see what my box is back up.
Ah, it is. Puff box 7 is live. It's that
easy. I literally just plug it in.
That's
awesome. I just got to do that with the
rest of them and we will have eight
boxes.
Nice. They didn't ship one of
them. Oh, cuz it's at main gear. I'm
dumb. Okay, I'm confused
now. The end log should not be null. It
should be have something there. Yes.
Well, actually end log
is that's a it's not a a pointer. Enlog
is
just right.
Why is an a log star? Oh, wait. Why is
envelar?
Is that a big deal? Yeah, that's
probably it. Why does that matter?
I think it expects it to not be a a
pointer.
But again, why does that matter though?
Let me see.
I mean, yeah, I guess there's no reason
why. Oh, wait, wait. So, that that's got
to be it,
right? But wait, like don't kill this.
Make a new term and then run in the new
term. Yeah. No, I'm going to keep the
debug session
I don't even know why I made I think
before the old log struck stuff it had
them be a pointer. So,
works. That's got to be zeroing out a
lot of additional things, right?
see. I hate the arrow syntax, man. I
don't know why they need to make that
separate like dot versus arrow. All
right.
Uh parenthesy remove
that. Yeah, it should be
Now it's just training in the CPU. Let
me try.
Yeah. I'm going to have to rebuild.
The new tutorial does have a log like
not as a pointer.
Okay. Yeah. I so I think what happened
was the old way you used to do logs like
the whole well the old way it wasn't
required like you could do it however
but with the new thing since I'm looking
for log right I expect you to have log
I'm I'm still confused as to why having
it in a pointer makes it behave because
if you have it in a pointer and I
iterate from the memory address then the
pointer's eight bytes and after that I'm
overwriting your stuff,
right? Yeah. Okay, I guess that makes
sense. Yeah,
cuz I have like there's no way there's
no other way for me to do it and see,
right? Like I have to just iterate over
the bites like of size of log, right?
Yeah.
You have like one M.
I thought I disabled that. No, I didn't.
That like I don't know.
See, but now in 3 instead of giving you
something dumb, it gives you an API
usage error. Hey, yeah, that's good.
What is segments though? Trajectory
segments.
Okay. So, there's like you have more
agents than you have storage for
segments.
Oh, right.
We sanity check things, you know. Yeah,
I know. That is always good.
Oh, You
know the thing I'm going to have to do
here. I just installed two more uh more
birdhouses.
Um I'm going to have to see what bird
claims what house. I might have to kick
I'm gonna have to like if one of the
ugly ones claims one of them, I'm gonna
have to kick him out.
The goal is uh like bluebirds,
cardinals, orals, like the pretty
ones. So, it's like if some like sparrow
or whatever comes, I'm going to have to
like kick a sparrow out of the bird
house. You
Okay, so this actually seems to be
working now. Um, I think that was just
it.
We got it. Yeah, I think that's it. It
seems to be actually training now. So,
oh, wait, hold on a sec. If I give you a
box or two, can you run uh can you get
like some like some good agents?
I'mma try. I'm I honestly would like
some help with that, though, because
I want that. I want setting good
defaults and such this week. Yeah.
You do the little checklist though like
make sure all your OBS state data is
like kind of reasonably normalized and
stuff. Yeah. No, we've gone over that. I
mean, you did a whole I really haven't
changed much since you reviewed it. Like
hardly anything, honestly. So,
I also This one is such a cool item.
definitely want even if it's hard to get
like, you know, a full agent
architecture, I want to get uh like a
demo of some type on the website. No, me
as well. Yeah.
Uh you know, something that's a little
concerning to me is that even though
these bird feeders represent infinite
food, the birds will uh still fight over
the literally unlimited food reserves. I
hope we don't do the exact same thing as
people with AI.
Who knows? One sec. Kill a fly. I think
it's kind of unfortunately I think it's
kind of humane.
Here you go.
Freaking bane of my existence here is
all the bugs. Everything else is a great
number of bugs needs to come down
substantially.
What other bugs do you know about? What?
What other bugs do you know about? Oh,
no, no, no. I mean the literal bugs
flying around the room. Oh, yeah.
Different kind. Yeah, that is really
That's literally that's what I do is I
crush bugs and I crush
bugs and then I train and I train.
That's what I do.
I train myself. I train agents. I crush
the bugs in the room. I crush the bugs
in the
hood. Okay. So, uh you got 3% end of
time, but garbo training
speed. Yeah. See, look the forward 40%.
This is comes back to like uh um multi-
whatever it was multi-discreet being
super slow. Are you on latest torch and
everything? Yep. All right. So, you've
got how many?
So, it's two drs
with two drones per N. Is it two? N
agents is one though. So, it's
256 times 16 is
4096, right? Mhm. Okay, so your forward
pass batch size is pretty damn small.
Oh, if I bump up number of M's though,
it's I think it was like the trajectory
or something. So, I did a sweep on that
and it really seemed to like a smaller
number of M's, like potentially even
128, which is not great for speed, but
much better for training. We should try
that again though cuz like the code's
gotten better. Um, so the the other
thing is you have it quad buffered right
now and that's got to be because your M
is slow, right? Oh, this. Yeah, at least
in Yeah, this definitely is the fastest.
Um,
so if I swap to
continuous uh Oh, wait. Continuous is
true. Oh, also I can like get like I
have like 7800k with a fiveway
multiddiscrete.
Oh, I actually I actually need to fix
multidiscreet because multidiscreet
technically won't run them
correctly. Did I mess this up? Is this
is it backwards somehow? What?
Cuz somehow continuous is false is
faster.
I would also highly suggest not doing
continuous because from my tests um the
discrete just trains way better. No, I
know. But I'm I'm just conf I don't
know. I gotta so I think I got to fix
multidiscreet. Um because I need
Yeah. So where was that?
Oh, there's one more.
So basically to make things simpler, I'm
just uh what was it? Oh, ready to go.
See? Oh, that's right. That's what I'm
doing.
nice. Yeah. So what I need to do which
won't be difficult for to make it easier
because I used to pass like two
different action buffers into the M then
use one or the other depending but now I
just basically in the MC code I just
assume the action buffer is always
continuous. You only have fiveway multi
discrete. It shouldn't be that bad.
Yeah. I just need to convert like when
I'm using multiscreet I just need to
convert multiscreet to continuous
huh policy. Yeah.
Um, I mean, yeah, I wanted to see the
definition of the action encoder or the
action decoder
right here. All right. You have it done
correctly.
Yeah. Yeah. You I mean, you've looked
over it before. Well, there are two ways
to do it and I think that one's slightly
faster.
How? Which what is the continuous or
non-ontinuous? No, you have it. There's
there are two ways to do multi-discreet
and you have it slightly the correct
way. It's good. Okay. Um let's think
what
else. How big is the obs? Is it 11 by 11
or how big? Yeah, it's 11 by 11 plus
some other stuff. Yeah, that's not bad.
Yeah, the obs are not
huge. It shouldn't be 278k then.
pretty
slow. What's the I do Oh, go ahead.
What's mini batch size?
Uh I think I just have them all defaults
right now. Okay. Try 32K real quick.
How fast that is?
Oh, I put
fly. Okay, that
[Music]
helps. Seems to
help. All
right. Is that not faster?
It is faster. It kind of flickers
between 250 and like 3 something. 330
350. Kind of
weird, but yeah, it it does seem to be
faster.
Yeah, that learn was is down to 23. You
have 21% MISK time in train.
That is not a field that usually has
high MISK time.
What is uh train misk
doing? What even is there in train misk?
train puff advantage? Do you not have
the kernel?
I should.
Well, you would have to actually because
the CPU pullback doesn't work correctly.
Yeah.
Uh yeah, that's that should be fast. The
kernel for that should be fast.
You should not have 25% time in that.
Well, once I get uh It shouldn't take
long. I'm going to get lunch, but then
once I get uh
Yeah, I want 2.7. All right. Yeah, good.
How do you check that again? Easy way to
check
that version.
Well, in from Python.
I'll just do this.
Yeah.
Okay. We probably don't need torch
vision and torch audio, right?
Probably not. But they just got
automatically installed. I don't know.
It's not going to hurt. I mean, so I can
cut them off the container.
Yeah, I don't think we use it. Yeah,
this is definitely faster with high
minion batch.
Well, that will change learning
dynamics, FYI.
Yeah, but uh one of the like the biggest
thing lately for us has been
like 4K. Will we do like 8K agents at
least? Oh, that is a very very nice. One
second. No way. I was going to get a
picture. The nicest one I've seen.
Um yeah, the biggest thing for us has
been like going to 4K uh in the like
inference pass at least 4k agents. So if
it's double buffered that's 8192 total
agents and then 32k mini batch and what
you just do is batch size is like 64
times the total number of agents or
whatever.
Yeah, I need
to later today or maybe tomorrow I
should be able to clean this up and then
open this up for another PR. Um, and
then hopefully you'll just be able to
like play with it. So, I'm going to
actually run some experiments on it too
because we will get you some boxes. I
got to go plug all the boxes in.
Yeah, I'm going to be kind of strapped
for time this week though in terms of
running running experiments and stuff.
Well, you just leave going.
Yeah. Well, that's true. I got I can do
that. Yeah, but it's stable.
Well, yeah. It doesn't really seem
learning anything with this, but yeah,
I'll have to play with it.
It's like not This is against a sitting
duck. It's not winning like at
all. Uh let's see. You've
got defaults. Okay. So, the reason that
this is your learning rate's going to be
way too high for a policy
size. H copy the learning rate from
tower climb real
quick. This is one of the things that
algorithm algorithmic improvements will
eventually solve for us from uh okay
tower. Yeah. Was that from tower climb?
Yeah. Really?
Mhm.
Yeah. Isn't that higher the default?
Yeah, that's
weird. Oh, but something is screwy here
because
005 real quick. See if it does anything
like that.
0 0.005.
Yeah. Okay.
for most I'm going to have to get all
the new boxes fixed and then we're going
to start running like sweeps on
everything.
Nice. Yeah, that'll be cool.
It's a good thing to do at the moment
cuz I'm kind of Mhm.
kind of tired lately. Up to do like the
other harder
work. Yeah, it doesn't really seem to be
doing any better. I mean, I'll I'll have
to give it a bit, but it should be able
to learn to do some like win and do
something.
Yeah, we'll have to play with it. Well,
I'll have to double check that with the
same params like or I'll have to double
check that the uh Syon binding is
actually trained similarly or
something just to make sure I didn't
screw anything up and I don't think I
should have.
Yeah, like that's a CUDA kernel for a
not ridiculous
operation. But I don't know if BPT
horizon is like is that set weird or
like I didn't set it. Should be 64 then.
Yeah, but that shouldn't be
high like at
all. So you're leaking perf there. 14%
leak on copy. That's just ob
size fortunately.
Yeah. And I've gotten that down as much
as I could. I can't really make it
because you know like I've I've I yeah
I've told you I've encoded it like half
of it's like bytes and half of it are
floats roughly. So I've done my part to
make the obs as small as it can get
basically.
And to be fair I like that is when I
eventually come back to infro though
I've done so much info lately it's going
to be mostly I think sims and algorithms
for a bit. Um, but next time I come back
to intro, hopefully 314 has fixed
threading and uh threading is actually
going to make it easier to buffer GPU
data transfer.
Gotcha. Yeah, that'll be
nice. Yeah, I I don't remember seeing
train MISK before. That seems to be new.
I think it's just new on Well, I just
split MIS. Yeah, it's new. I split eval
and train like to have their separate
MISK function. It would have just been
MISK before.
Oh, okay. That makes sense. I'm just
saying I don't remember train miss to be
that big. But yeah, maybe that's because
or maybe I just didn't have a miss. I
don't know. But anyways, it's there now.
And so now you can actually tell.
Yeah. Yeah. 25% or like it's crazy.
[Music]
It's weird.
Okay. How is this not adding up though?
Train is 16 seconds and eval is 34
seconds. Yeah. So it's this is this a
thing with the latest um we don't run it
every
step. So those times are just above what
we've like profiled.
Oh why is that? Just to save time. Yeah
because the profiling overhead can
actually be uh substantial.
H I guess you have to
synchronize. Yeah, the overhead for me
wouldn't matter, I guess, because I'm
not going to reach that. But when you
get up to them like multiple millions, I
guess it makes a difference, right?
Yeah. Well, it depends as well cuz like
you call you have like very expensive
CUDA synchronized calls, right? Mhm. It
just screws up your training graph
completely.
[Music]
Yeah. The thing is though, if I turn
sitting duck to false, it'll get even
slower because then like the AI is going
to play against and the AI is like not
super is kind of
slow. The M time really isn't that much
more though. There it is.
There it is. Yep.
Somehow it's winning more against the
scripted
bot. Probably because this that's just
the scripted bot accidentally killing
itself and so the other agent happens to
win if I had to guess. Whereas the
sitting duck the sitting duck is never
going to win ever. Well, no, no, no. The
sitting duck is never going to kill
itself. So, the only way the agent is
going to win is by actually killing the
opponent. But with a scripted agent,
scripted agent will some like rarely
kill itself. So it'll actually win by
not actually doing anything
good occasionally. Which I think is
another Oh, why is explain variance an I
don't know. I saw
that. That seems weird. Weird. Oh, and
what is important? Is that like a
experience buffer thing?
Yeah, it's just going to stay at one. I
should probably remove that. Well, no
it's not actually. It's like so
technically it can shift because it has
to do with um it has to do with how the
priority buffer samples experience.
Gotcha.
I don't know. There probably tons of
things I can improve, but like you got
to like release stuff eventually, right?
And like it's already it's just like
literally it's the results were sitting
on here. It's like RL is a different
field.
It's a different field. So
yeah, pretty good.
Okay. Yeah.
Well, get that fix uh in and
uh let's see. I'm going to go do
boxes and then I'm going to run
experiments here.
240. Yeah. So, I'm going to go do that
and I'm going to probably set up
experiments and maybe I'll do a couple
other things and that'll be most of
today.
Cool.
Yeah, I got to go do some stuff and then
I'll try to get a PR for this in like
soonish. Yeah. And I'll try to get you
whatever. What box were you on? I've
been on box two. I'll try to get that
back for you. Okay, cool. Thanks.
here. Oh, cool. My family gets here in
an hour, so I'll go.
Okay, I'm going to start on the uh the
boxes. Do I'm just going to mute this.
I'll be in the background setting up
boxes for a little bit. Then uh we'll
get the experiments going.
Okay,
back potentially
back. We have to
see any of the machines came online.
Uh, they did
weird. I must have the cables plugged in
wrong.
H, let me go check why the boxes are not
back online. I plugged them all in.
I wait for my hands to work
again and
uh check out whether they came online.
So everything but
three and
zero came back
I'm going to go check the wiring on
those in a second.
Whenever I deadlift without
straps, like over
and hands
right, I'm going to go check and see if
uh what I did with three and zero
Hello, welcome. Think AI will be able to
get beyond pattern beyond pattern. Well,
it's already definitely beyond pattern
recognition and become smarter than
humans. Yes. though I don't know whether
the current approaches uh will scale
that way where it's like smarter than
humans in every capacity. I don't know
whether the current approaches will
scale for that. I actually think that
the stuff I'm working on has a pretty
likely chance of being
relevant. So we just got puffer one came
back
online. So I haven't hooked up the login
box yet. And then the only one that
hasn't come back up that should have is
Pupper 3. Let me just go figure out why
box three is uh still offline.
was just a bad
cable. Brand new cable was
see. It's getting signal now.
So it
should do I have to go reboot the
thing for it to come
online. This is
weird. It's definitely getting signal.
It should be coming back
online, but I do not see it.
online. Go plug a keyboard in maybe. Oh
no, there it goes. It's
back. Buffer box is back online.
setup. It's a solid solid setup. Now,
we're going to add two more tiny boxes
to this uh this week. And then we've got
capacity here. So you can see the size
of these shelves. Got capacity for 40 or
machines. Going to add lots and lots of
stuff in
pm 4 pm is uh when this other guy wanted
to chat.
So need the restroom real quick. I'm
going to get one more good set
in. Probably use straps. We'll
see. I don't know. Maybe
not. And then uh we will start on
setting up experiments, I guess.
Well, that's my
uh compound sorted for today.
Hello YouTube
folks. Been a little bit of a scattered
day here, but
uh main
progress is the machines, the little
blinking lights behind me.
finally back
online
and they're here on prem where I can
maintain them
myself is
solid. So that
is I believe that's eight total GPUs
there plus mine
here nine GPUs for use uh in
Puffer and uh we're getting 12
more right on two machines and those are
going to be here on
Friday. Got 20 minutes before this call.
Um, so yeah, why don't
we see about some experiments? Okay.
right. So, this
was the driver update I did.
Um, I kind of need my keyboard and
mouse to fix
that. And I don't have a spare one yet.
I need to get a spare the shitty
keyboard and
mouse. Okay, I'm going to just borrow
these for a
second so that I can real quick go get
that set up. We can run our
experiments. I just need
um this is keyboard.
Okay, hardware maintenance
today. For some reason, that machine had
fast boot. I'm not fast boot. It had
that do, but secure
boot, which uh al is also known as the
just break your computer for no apparent
reason
setting. That's all it's useful for is
breaking your damn computer for no
reason.
I got to go behind my desk to plug this
in. Then we can actually run this. And
then I got meeting
Lovely. We're
done.
Finally. That. So, to be fair, the setup
for that because I have the nice racks
like the way they are behind me and
because of how it's all wired, like
setting that up was so much easier than
the way way jankier garage setup that I
had before. Like, that wasn't even that
bad.
Okay, so we actually have our setup. Now
what I have to do for
this branch
all check out.
Look at
that. It
works. So
900 p.m. Morning for you. No, I'm on
East
Coast. Okay, so this is just a
token and we should be able to get our
sweep.
So this is just the two basic M's for
now. I do wonder if we have the config
set up correctly.
me. M is
eight. That's
reasonable. I think is very
reasonable. Detach. I don't know if you
can see it behind
me. Can you see it if you look really
close in the stream? That's going to
telescope infinitely. Okay, you can't
see it in the screen uh the stream, but
I have a monitor behind me that has that
same T-up session open. So, I actually
can see it behind me just training on
the on the monitor that's sitting
there. So, I can just go monitor uh and
see how my sweep is doing.
Yeah. No, it's cuz it's out of focus. I
think if I go back there and if I didn't
have the ISO so low, you'll be able to
see it. The uh this is not the final
lighting for this room. It's not
anywhere near as dark as it looks on the
stream, but it's going to look way
better than this. We basically we just
have like temporary utility lights for
the time being.
So, that's the last thing that needs to
be done for this building is the uh the
lights. Got a cool setup. Thank you. See
if the camera can focus
it. We just got the uh the eight
boxes. We got uh the 15090 server, 7
uh 4090 server. There's the login server
that I haven't plugged back in yet.
Obviously all the gym
equipment, training facility, training
for me, training for
idea, those are high-end PCs. Yeah.
Well, there's I mean they're like
basically maximum specs for uh gaming
desktops and then we use them for RL. So
they're like 4090s with well we have
Intel chips in a bunch of them and the
Intel chips suck. Um they're still like
14900 uh 14900 Ks or whatever, but um
yeah, those don't don't buy Intel chips
these days. Uh, and then we got the one
the really nice one which is well I have
the similar thing here 9950X with 5090s
and all sorts of
stuff. Um, and then the ones that are
arriving, we got two tiny boxes arriving
this week and each of those tube
machines will have four, no, six 4090s
in them. So that'll add 12 GPUs to our
training capacity.
solid. Yeah, Main
Gear. They've been really good with the
service. I recommend them.
Um they're quotes have gotten way too
high these days because of the tariffs.
I got to call them to see if with the
pause um they're lower now. I got to ask
him because they they gave me like
reasonable quotes and then with the
tariffs they jumped up like two grand
like okay I'm not doing that. Um but now
like I think that
the the distributors have kind of just
taken advantage of it and like they're
not bringing the prices back down to
where they should. Um so I'm just not
buying them until they get like we're
not paying seven grand a desktop. That's
ridiculous. Um should be like five and a
half maybe.
I got the tiny boxes in the meantime
because those were uh those were pretty
Yeah, the server is all lined up on the
middle
shelf. I've got this whole server rack
here that just all this has is um backup
like the backup power supply
um and like switches for now, but you
know, we have a server rack so we can
mount whatever we want in that.
Um, yeah. Is this Discord server public?
Yeah,
discord.gg/puffer. Man, all the code I'm
writing here is open source, too. Like,
you can just hop in and build cool stuff
with us. In fact, contributors get
access to these
machines. Yeah, this is what I do all
day. I do open source reinforcement
learning research, algorithm dev,
simulation development. Um, you know,
all sorts of different things. Uh, all
the code's free and open source. Most of
the environments are written by
contributors. Uh, I teach people who
haven't been in the space and want to
learn like the RL side. I teach people
that as long as they'll put in the dev
work, you know, and uh, we advance the
state of science. That's what we do.
the release that we have coming soon,
like we basically have the release done.
We're just running final experiments. It
completely changes the field. Like it's
a it makes the field a completely
different field from where it was just a
few months ago.
In fact, I have um there's a guy I'm
supposed to be chatting with right now
where I don't know where he is cuz he
uh he popped in to set up a meet for
like right now on the just literally
from the chat here. Uh and he's got like
an ant colony sim. So, we're probably
going to talk about that on the stream
for a bit and uh unless he wants to do
private for some reason, but probably
we'll just talk talk about that on the
stream and uh see if we can get this
into into Puffer Lab because mainly
looking for contributed MS like if you
want to see some cool demos, they're on
puffer.ai. Sorry, the GitHub to help us
out. Um whoops.
Like these are all
environments. I wrote this one, this
one, and this one. The rest of them are
by contributors and they're all very
very high performance environments. They
run very fast and we train reinforcement
learning agents on them. And you can
watch some of our agents playing the
games in your browser. Many of them are
superhuman. This is just like a little
tiny neural network that we've trained
and it runs in your browser.
you. So, yeah, that's pretty much the
deal. Like, I finished my PhD a year
ago. I decided that uh I wanted to try
to revamp the field that I did my PhD
in, but to do it in a way that wasn't so
constrained by uh
academia. And I've kind of like come up
with a bunch of the tech behind this.
And it's now gotten to the point where
it's actually fairly straightforward for
new people to come in and uh do research
that before would have been way way way
harder. So, it's a lot more accessible.
You can do a lot of work a lot faster
than normal.
Wonder where this guy
is. Let me check my XDMs in case he like
messaged me
I don't know how I'm supposed to find
this
guy.
Like this is Mtan, but
like none of these are his
uh profile pick.
He sent me an
email. An
email would have my email.
Oh, well, I have a couple other cool uh
emails in my inbox. That's exciting
stuff for Puffer, but I do not have a
meeting
invite. So, I guess I'm just going to
chill here and hope he comes by. Unless
he's in the
Okay. Well, we will see if he uh he
drops by. We'll take a quick look at
some experiments, and if not, I will
just start working on uh the
terraforming sim.
like a reasonable thing to do,
right? We do a little bit of
terraforming. So, this is the new No,
this is the old sweep for
breakout. New sweep for
Paul. All right.
So yeah, this will be honestly this
whole sweep should run in like an hour.
The problem
is the hyper pram sweep algorithm that
we have right now. The way I have it set
up, it's like it takes a while to
actually suggest
hyperparameters. I should probably do
something about that.
Hello. Hey, do you want me to do this
off stream?
Um, I don't have your camera on the
stream right now.
I would uh that that would be a little
better. Yeah. Okay, that's fine by me.
Um, cool. Appreciate that. Let me just
uh Hey guys, I'm going to end stream
now. I'm going to go have this uh this
call and I might be back in the evening.
If not, I'll be back in the morning. And
YaK uh yeah, there is a company behind
this as well, but all the code is open
source. Stop.